Gary W. Goldstein: There is a wonderful quote…it’s
escaping me for a moment from a great science
fiction writer I believe it was who said “You
can’t allow your manuscripts to gather dust
in a dresser drawer…”
Film Courage: Let’s talk about marketing
a screenplay.
When does it happen?
How important is it?
How does a screenwriter do it effectively?
Gary W. Goldstein: It’s not important…it’s
essential.
It’s crucial, it is life-affirming and it
is absolutely the responsibility of any talent,
any creative to market themselves.
If it’s a writer and it’s a script or
a book or some product…time to market it!
That’s what you’ve got to do.
And here is what most people don’t understand,
it should be and it is, fun.
If I take that same writer to a cocktail party
and I put a drink in their hand and say “Tell
these people, they are fascinated by you and
what you do, talk about it.
They’re going to talk non-stop.
You will not be able to shut them up.
But if you, on the other hand say, “Ahh…you’ve
got a script.”
and you’re at home.
Pick up the phone and call someone.
No.
They don’t want to do it.
Suddenly marketing is a negative.
It’s a bad thing.
It’s all in how you perceive it.
Marketing and sharing your talent with the
world should be a joy.
It should be your purpose.
The problem is, people thing so narrowly.
99.9 percent of writers who have a screenplay
ready to go to market.
They’ve rewritten it, it’s ready, they’ve
tested it, beautiful.
What do they do?
They automatically think “I need to send
it to agents.
I need to send it to producers.”
Then they stop.
The thought ends.
Oh my gosh.
That does not sound like a lot of fun because
who are the people getting all the scripts?
Producers and agents.
I would look at it and say “Let me research
this.”
What are the kind of projects that are exciting
that have been produced successfully (projects
that people love) that are similar over the
last handful of years?
Whether it’s TV, film or whatever.
And I’ll make a list and I’ll do a spreadsheet.
And I’ll list the cinematographer and the
editor and the script supervisor and the casting
director and everybody but the producer and
the agent.
And I will start calling them and reaching
out to their assistants.
And saying “I’m calling because…Oh my
gosh…You guys were involved with one of
my favorite projects of all time.
I so admire the work.
And I have something spiritually very similar.
I’d love your advice.
Would you be my 5-minute mentor?
Would you play with me on this a little bit?”
There are endless conversations you can have.
You develop a rapport with people because
you share a common interest.
That’s the key!
And if you can get them interested in a conversation
then you can get them soon on the third call
reading your script.
You’re not asking anything of them.
When you call an agent, you’re asking them
to represent you.
That’s a huge ask!
When you send your script to a producer saying
“Will you produce this?”
Oh my God!
That’s the biggest ask of any.
Because what that means is the producer has
to invest several years on their own dime
to create value and make this a reality.
When you ask an agent to represent you or
a producer to produce your film, you have
to understand there is almost nothing in it
for them at the outset.
They’re going to invest their time, their
belief and their relationships on your behalf
for no money.
That’s the reality.
But if you make it about something else, if
you make it about a shared common interest
that’s exciting and fun and those people
can become your ambassadors and backdoor that
script over to that agent or that script over
to [another], it comes over in a different
package.
It comes in a different context.
That’s where magic happens.
That’s where alchemy kicks in.
I could talk about that for about three days.
Question for the Viewers: Are you excited
to share a script when it’s finished?